hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game a lot of you recommended
it is from yesterday's chessable Masters
uh or the the Champions Chester chess B
Master 2024 Wesley so versus ala fua
they played two games one of them ended
in a draw and one of them most certainly
did not it's a it's a very short game
but uh it features a very cool tactic
that I'm sure you guys will enjoy uh
trying to figure out with the the pause
the video moment and we're also going to
discuss what happened um uh in in some
other games and what is what is next to
happen so Wesley with the white pieces
opens with Pawn to E4 now this is rapid
time format 10 minutes per player so of
course players do not have uh a lot of
time to discuss um variations we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to C4 going for the Italian game
and now Knight to F6 the two knights
defense where Knight to G5 is very
rarely seen on the on the absolute top
level so Pawn to D3 the so-called modern
Bishop's opening Bishop to C5 and Bishop
to G5 this is the fourth most popular
continuation but it seems that lately
we've been seeing quite a lot of it and
I think Wesley here decided to go for it
with the white pieces just uh get ala to
attack with the black pieces and I think
he was um ready for that as when you see
a bishop to G5 line uh you will also see
H6 G5 and black will go for an attack on
the king side so H6 Bishop to H4 Pawn to
D6 and now C3 uh Pawn to A6 and pawn to
A4 now old been play before nothing new
here Bishop back to A7 uh Knight B to D2
and now uh Pawn to G5 going after the
bishop Bishop to G3 and queen to E7
maybe we're preparing to move the bishop
also maybe maybe you're going to Castle
Queen side but more often than not you
Castle kingside here uh so kingside
castles and now Knight to D7 REM
maneuvering the Knight and making room
for that pawn at maybe be pushed to F5
but also rman ring the Knight maybe to
to f8 then to E6 or to G6 then to F4 so
many possibilities Here pawn to B4 by
Wesley uh Knight to f8 and now Pawn to
B5 of course makes sense white will go
for Queens side attack Knight to A5 and
Bishop to D5 we have Pawn to H5 going
for Pawn to H4 to trap the bishop so
Pawn to H4 and now G4 attacking the
Knight Knight to E1 and the position is
still a known one in last year's Fay
World Cup David naar had this against
prananda and prananda continued with the
uh well with the absolute top move
recommended by the engine Knight to G6
but here ala deviates with Pawn to C6
and it is now as of move 16 that we have
a completely new game so it's not like
it's a a weaker move uh the engine gives
both Knight to G6 and C6 as great for
black uh Knight to G6 just being the the
top move C6 being the second move but as
ala did spend a minute uh trying to
figure out what to play here uh i' I'd
say that maybe he doesn't have this
prepared so he just decided to play Pawn
to C6 here uh so okay we have Bishop
back to A2 and now uh Knight to G6 and
queen to B1 now this is um I believe the
idea that Wesley had when he decided to
go for that Bishop to G5 line as he sets
a deadly trap here for alera he
sacrifices the H for Pawn but not really
as the pawn cannot be captured however
alera does go for a knight captures an
H4 he doesn't care what Wesley prepared
and Wesley just shows it to him Pawn to
B
uh this attacks the bishop and well
really what it does is it traps the
Knight on A5 now Queen to B4 and the
Knight cannot be saved you cannot play
B6 to defend the knight uh and that's
pretty much it Wesley will win a piece
here but alza probably did see this so
he just decided to uh not uh react to
this but rather to sacrifice a piece and
now okay if you go back with Bishop to
B8 then you can just capture here and
win the Knight with Queen to B4 that's
the idea but ala goes back with the
Knight Knight to G6 he says you can have
the the bishop on A7 I'm just going to
keep the Knight here and attack your
king side so okay B captures on A7
Wesley does take the free Bishop Pawn to
H4 and now Bishop to H2 we have Queen to
G5 uh preparing to further Advance those
pawns and also attacking the undefended
Knight on D2 and now Queen to B4 putting
pressure on the Knight here and now uh
what do you play here do you go for uh
Queen captures on E2 well no do you go
for B6 to defend the Knight also no h
what ala does is Pawn to G3 and here
Wesley is down to four minutes on the
clock ala down to three minutes on the
clock but I think uh Wesley decided not
to burn too much time discussing this
and he just played Queen captures on A5
which is definitely a suboptimal idea
here you either Play Bishop captures on
F7 or you just go for f captures and G3
and I'm going to show you why it's so
complicated because after F captures on
G3 and this is the only line pretty much
I'm going to explore as you know it's a
it's a fairly short game Bishop captures
on G3 and after Queen captures now
Bishop captures on F7 check King to E7
and let's say Bishop captures on G6 and
you might be thinking well of course why
wouldn't uh Wesley play this it looks I
mean it looks incredible well you have
to also think about Queen to E3 check
and after Rook to F2 Rook to H1 with
check and after Rook captures and queen
captures how do you now deal with just
moving the bishop and Rook to h8 is this
just game over for white well to
calculate all of this I believe Wesley
would have to burn a lot of time because
you have to find ideas like Knight E to
F or Knight Knight E to F3 and then
after the bishop moves going for Rook to
h8 you can even play Bishop to H7 and
now after Rook the h8 you just bring a
Queen into the game and this is how uh
White solves all of his problems you uh
either move the rook and then Rook to F1
comes and the attack is over or you
capture on H7 and then you block Knights
to H2 and there's just no way for black
to deliver Checkmate once you you give
white one move uh it's all over there's
no way to do anything Rook captur on H2
is insufficient to get some sort of a
perpetual and if you prepare Checkmate
uh a simple Knight F1 and there there is
no Checkmate so that's um that's the
problem so Wesley definitely should have
played either first captures or Bishop
captures uh both move orders work but he
played Queen captures on A5 and now ala
gets the attack G captures on H2 check
King to H1 much better than capturing on
H2 and now Queen captures on D2 also win
some material back Queen to C7 now if um
uh well if you go after the pawn here
then Queen captures on D6 will prevent
castling so he castles and now Queen
captures on D6 not just grabbing a pawn
but also preparing a deadly trick uh if
for example the pawn is captured then
just Queen captures and G6 as I'm sure
none of you forgot about our good friend
the light s Bishop on A2 so instead
after Queen captures on D6 King to G7
stopping Queen captures on G6 and now
Knight to F3 attacking the queen uh
Queen captures on C3 and now uh it's a
it's a very tricky position where both
players have two minutes on the clock um
Wesley 2 minutes 11 seconds ala 2
minutes and 9 seconds and you have to
play Rook 8 to B1 or something like Rook
F to C1 or you know just not make some
sort of a uh critical positional uh
error which Wesley did he played Pawn to
D4 and by playing Pawn to D4 look what
he did he allowed the queen to have
access to the Knight on F3 which makes
Al's next move a no-brainer really and
he plays Pawn to H3 if uh Wesley does
not play D4 then this doesn't really do
all that much you can just play G
captures on H3 but still it's such a
critical position that only only a
particular set of moves are uh truly
winning for alza Knight to G5 H captures
on G2 check King captures and now Rook
to h8 to to have the option of H1 Queen
so Wesley stops IT King to H1 and now
comes Bishop to H3 putting pressure on
The Rook here uh Bishop captures on F7
Wesley breaks through now threatens
Queen captures on G6 and it seems like
it's alza who is getting destroyed here
but there is one only one move that wins
the game so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this idea for ala uh
while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
figuring out that you have to sacrifice
more than one piece and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Bishop to G2 with check I would do it in
slow motion but there's only one square
you know so it'd be weird uh but yeah
Bishop to G2 check and there's nothing
yeah there's only one move King captur
on G2 and now comes the real punch line
H1 Queen that's it this is what alza
played and he was in this position un
move 33 that Wesley so resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the only move is as the queen covers
the the third rank the only move you
have is to capture with the Rook as also
The Rook covers the H1 Square so you
cannot capture with the King and after
Rook captures there's Knight to F4 check
again the king cannot go up the board
King to F1 or G1 doesn't really matter
and now Queen captures on A1 is
Checkmate so uh by playing this D4 move
Wesley really just you know uh ruined
everything he he he worked hard for this
game uh but what are you going to do
it's rapid you don't have all the time
in the world and you know has to be has
to be every decision has to be made
quickly uh so E2 is covered G2 is
covered the queen delivers check and
this is of course Checkmate so uh always
a tricky tricky uh uh business you know
going for this bishop to G5 line uh like
I said it is the fourth most popular
move but in in speed chess it is played
very very often and it will uh sort of
invite H6 G5 and Wesley did prepare that
Queen to B1 move uh but it wasn't U you
know it wasn't prepared well enough uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending
such a gem really wonderful to see and
yeah it's um you know Wesley was
supposed to be playing in the candidates
tournament but then you know he decided
to spend his uh you know Christmas with
with his family uh and ala decided to
grind and he overtook um Wesley so in
rating and you know just uh took his
place uh but yeah that's that's what you
get when you decide to spend Christmas
with your family there will always be
someone who is willing you know to to to
grind during holidays uh so that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Gard hlan
Jeremy anos Carl Weinberg rajashri churi
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions but also
whatever happens in the Chess World uh
today we have the finals between Magnus
Carlson and Dennis lazovic so probably a
game or two from that event H see you
soon